hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
weltweite gibt es ein richtig tolles
rezept wir werden nämlich sozusagen
pesto kartoffel machen allerdings ist es
kein richtiges pastor sondern es sind
grüne kartoffel mit einer grünen soße im
gelben trikot und bohnen und askese
frick hatte ich glaube er lacht mich aus
okay doch gut ich werde zuerst einmal
die kartoffeln zu bereiten und später
die gc frikadellen und 4 vorne mal
gipfel taten für die fenster kartoffel
brauche ich ein glück kartoffeln dann
nehme ich jetzt die kleinen also die
zwillinge die habe ich bereits gekocht
und abkühlen lassen
ich habe ich 500 gramm grüne bohnen ich
habe ich etwas salz eine unbehandelte
zitrone davon brauche sagt und schale
jeweils einen halben bund petersilie
minze und basilikum
hier habe ich noch einen telefonisch 200
gramm joghurt das ist der zehnprozentige
etwas olivenöl vier frühlingszwiebeln
tomaten und pfeffer die kartoffeln sind
wir bereits gesagt gekocht und ich hab
sie abkühlen lassen
jetzt nämlich die bohnen die habe ich
bereits gesäubert und noch gewaschen und
gibt es jetzt hier in einem kleinen topf
da habe ich jetzt wasser und auch etwas
salz drin
wer jetzt schon aufkochen lassen und
etwa zwölf minuten garen sie sollten auf
jeden fall da noch bis haben
und ich werde in der zwischenzeit die
kartoffeln und pellen und sie dann in
grobe stücke schneiden
die kartoffeln habe ich jetzt kurz zur
seite gestellt und jetzt kann ich hier
die kräuter abzupfen und alles in eine
große schüssel geben sie den hof ist
wahr wird nämlich gleich die soße
püriert im prinzip ist es auch kein
richtiges pesto sondern eher ein joghurt
estro aber ihr könnt natürlich auch ein
richtiges fest zu machen kommt ein
bisschen mehr öl rein und das fehlt der
joghurt so finde ich einfach ein
bisschen frischer
hier gebe ich jetzt also noch den
joghurt mit dazu wenn er es gerne noch
leichter haben möchte neben einem 10
prozent sondern 38 5 prozent wie joghurt
sowie das ganze aber schön cremig jetzt
macht er honig
das salz und olivenöl natürlich und
jetzt gebe ich noch die zitronenschale
und auch den zitronensaft mit erzeugen
wenn jetzt wenn die zutaten gut pariert
die soße stelle ich jetzt kurz zur seite
und werde jetzt die frühlingszwiebeln in
feine ringe und die tomaten innviertel
schneiden
jetzt kann ich die sauce über die
kartoffeln geben und den treffer hatte
ich vergessen den füge ich jetzt auch
gleich hinzu
war schon mal vorsichtig durch film ist
david ich ein bisschen in die lauwarmen
kartoffeln einziehen
hier kommen jetzt noch die tomaten
betreiben und die zwiebel und ich habe
jetzt hier auch schon ganze bohnen
abgegossen und auch mit kaltem wasser
abgeschreckt
und die schneide ich jetzt in grobe
stücke und gebt mir dazu
ich kann das gut durchgemischt werden
und dann stelle ich es einfach abgedeckt
zur seite und kann euch schon mal die
zutaten für die käse frikadellen hier
vorne zeigen
für die käse frikadellen brauche ich 500
gramm rindfleisch das habe ich bereits
selbst durch den fleischwolf geweben
eine zwiebel die habe ich geschält und
halbiert etwas pfeffer und chili flocken
und 150 com beispiel das hackfleisch
gebe ich jetzt in eine große schüssel
und ich finds auch immer ganz gut
hackfleisch selbst herzustellen so weiß
ich einfach was drinsteckt und vor allem
kann ich den fettgehalt des fleisches
einfach selbst bestimmt die schiffe gebe
ich jetzt hier her und zwar wird jetzt
die zwiebel und der käse die wir beide
fein gerieben
die zutaten habe ich hier wird rein
gegeben hier kommen jetzt noch besser
und chili rhein pfalz gebe ich jetzt
nehme ich mir dazu denn der krise ist
eine chance an sich und bringt einfach
schon die perfekte wird somit das ganze
wird jetzt verknetet das mache ich jetzt
mit einem handschuh aber geht natürlich
auch ohne
und jetzt habe ich daraus etwa
zweieinhalb zentimeter große bändchen
die hackbällchen werden jetzt angebraten
ich habe etwas sonnenblumenöl in einer
beschichteten pfanne erhitzt damit die
hütte und da kommen selbst rein und es
dauert dann so etwa vier bis fünf
minuten bisher rund herum schön braun
sind
wenn alle fregatte in eingebrachten und
ella darf probieren et wier et fleisch
für einige probieren
na ja man hat uns am ihr vorhaben sich
vorm probieren gedrückt die war beinahe
frei für dich nein feucht ich nicht okay
stelle es mal kurz zur seite
den habe ich mal darauf skeptisch
und 17 ich hab dich fest
ba ddp
der apfel fällt nicht weit vom stamm
naja okay natürlich dass man mal
vorstellen
und dann hat er bei mir hat es gefallen
ich glaube ihr schmeckt also wenn sie
nichts sagt dann schmeckt so wie beim
papa und sie ist so genießt und schweigt
super es ist super hier krieges aus nein
weil du hast eben gesagt er will
spannung ich will früher probier mal
papa mama bei den frikadellen habe ich
natürlich keinen kein salz mit dabei war
der käse mit drin ist und wie schmeckt
der papa auf
habe ich aber die machen das ist ohne
salz gemacht dass kinder wenn ich bin
deshalb sehr wohl aber vor allem ist
einfach ein leckeres rezept das schmeckt
gleich dass er drückt einen lexus nur
mal eben auch die kartoffeln so leicht
an gemacht sind also durch den joghurt
ist eben nicht so schwer wie mit meinen
jetzt sogar in salz ringinger in die 49
ich kann es nicht glauben so und ich
weiß noch gar nicht ob ihm schmeckt es
auch gleich nein
und bei elvis gleich zu sein jedes
böhnchen gibt ein krönchen hier sein
papa spitzhacke element super dann
werden wir es nicht hier heute in der
küche stehen und essen sondern uns an
den tisch setzen und falls ihr das
rezept auch nachmachen möchte schaut
auch verließen das blog de vorbei da
steht normale fans genau und ich wünsche
euch viel spaß dabei guten appetit und
bis zum nächsten mal
es geht mal eine andere gabe hat der
aktivste dann im dekan peter nicola
mitte juli um 21
was eben zum dom gesagt hat der kamera
hat billy haben dinge die da kommen wir
essen wir haben hunger geld schafft es
gern hätten